this is the fda's food pyramid
for decades the predominant thought was
that if you follow it you would be quote
unquote healthy but does that pyramid
really apply to everyone
nutrition is not a one-size-fits-all
approach neither is weight loss neither
is prevention of chronic conditions and
that's because we are all so different
eating
is one of the most complex social
behaviors that we have
we have to do it we love to do it it's
in our genes to want to eat
what we eat is extremely important for
our wellness for our well-being for our
longevity and not just ours but those of
our families too
and so we want to make sure that the
food choices that we make every day
support health rather than
put us on a path to disease
[Music]
there are hundreds of diets to choose
from from atkins to keto to paleo
but the burgeoning field of
nutrigenomics and personalized nutrition
throws the idea of a diet working for
anyone out the window
scientifically there is really nothing
more intimate that our connection with
food and how it can affect our genes
the idea of personalized nutrition is
that we can discover what diet works
best for our genes
i often tell my patients that your genes
are not your destiny but they are your
predisposition
now we're delving a little further and
looking at our actual genetics what were
we born with what are the genes we were
born with what are the genes we want to
turn off what are the ones we want to
turn on how do we become a place where
we know our kids are going to grow up
and have an easier time knowing how to
structure their lifestyle prescription
to match
longevity nutrigenomics really looks at
us as the individual
[Music]
at the heart of nutrigenomics and
precision nutrition is understanding the
human genome
genetically speaking we are very similar
but if we look at those little outliers
outside of where we are similar
we have so many things that make us
different
depending on which variants we carry of
these genes what flavors of the genes we
carry they might affect the way our
brain our body our cells interact with
different nutrients
and those nutrients we consume can
switch certain genes on or off
so we have about 25 000 genes but in our
brain cells a set of genes are on and a
set of genes are off the genome and
looking at our dna is really kind of
what puts us aside from someone else and
says gosh i'm more at risk for this or i
would do better
lifting weights than i would running a
marathon so that's where our dna plays a
role
so the genetic switches are very similar
to the switches of light in your room
that can control how much
light you have whether it's on or off or
whether it's dial up or down
nutrients essentially help the molecular
machinery that can make these genetic
switches easier or harder to turn on or
off
and is there a possibility say of giving
people foods that are going to
affect those favorably
one of the most striking examples of how
food can drive biological processes by
interacting with the genome can be found
of all places in a beehive
when we usually think of food we think
mostly about its calories and nutrient
content but there is this whole other
side of food
that is much more intimately connected
with our biology and that is the ability
of nutrients to essentially inform and
shape our genome the blueprint that
drives all life
there are two kinds of bees queen bees
and worker bees queen bees
give rise to the entire colony queen
bees are fertile they give rise to every
other bee in the colony and they live
for years on the other hand worker bees
are sterile
they don't have any offspring and they
only live for a few weeks
what you might not know is that actually
worker bees and the queen bee are
genetically identical organisms what
shapes them into these two completely
different life forms is actually the
food they eat the queen bee when she's a
larva she feeds on this food called
royal jelly on the other hand the worker
bees mostly eat pollen
and this food that they get when they're
developing determines their physiology
and their anatomy for their lust of
their lives
obviously humans are not bees but the
amino acid methionine influences genetic
dials in humans and mice just like royal
jelly does with bees
methionine can be used to add a little
tag to the genetic switches or even to
the genetic blueprint and what this tag
does essentially it makes it harder for
the genes to be turned on and harder for
the genetic switches to be accessed and
so
it's very important to have a diet where
we have a balanced level of methionine
so that the genetic switches that ought
to be off remain off
ultimately this information hinges on
dietitians and doctors applying this
information to the real world
i never want my patient to look at a
gene and say well i have the genes so i
might as well just enjoy life instead i
want them to look at it and say i have
the gene what can i know from a
nutrigenomics perspective to
alter my lifestyle so that this gene
doesn't rear its ugly head
in terms of prevention of chronic
conditions in terms of weight management
it's really taking our general sense and
knowledge of the evidence-based
approaches to provide a diet that makes
sense some individuals have genetics
that make them more prone to be
deficient in folate or in b12 so we have
to really focus on those two when we're
sitting face to face with a client or a
patient and saying okay listen i don't
think you're getting enough folate and
you are genetically predisposed to not
being able to absorb enough of it so
let's talk about how we get that in our
diet
and diets based off genetic information
could lead to disease prevention that we
haven't seen before
we know that people that have a type of
untreatable epilepsy can actually live a
relatively good life by eating a
ketogenic diet
this idea that we can couple a certain
diet to treat a disease is now one of
the main avenue of investigation for the
treatment of cancer
there are many cancers that are caused
by diet right
for example for colon cancer
scientists know that the amino acid
serine is very important and so in
addition to treating the cancer with the
chemotherapeutics that are used for dead
cancers the idea is that what if now we
can deprive people of this amino acids
in ways that essentially make the cancer
cells more vulnerable take two cod
phillips drizzle of olive oil jerk
seasoning
give it a rub and that right there
is lean in 15.
nutrigenomics and precision nutrition is
one of those rare scientific fields that
overlaps with the instagram friendly
wellness industry
there is a lot of interest in this idea
of personalized nutrition and especially
how accessible it is to the public
you can go on google and type
personalized nutrition or
diet and genes and you will
find dozens of different companies that
offer this nutrition precision tests
one of those companies is routine
founded to get customers to take
vitamins more efficiently
i'm rachel sanders i'm ceo and
co-founder of routine
routine is a company that focuses on
optimizing health and human performance
with precision nutrition our members
come to us because they're looking for
really focusing on on total body health
and improving in areas more common
health conditions like stress fatigue
brain fog immune health support mood
balance and more they really come to us
because we have a tailored
approach and we create tailored products
specific to their individual needs and
individual biology
while many studies have found vitamins
and supplements don't do much to improve
overall health routine claims that their
personalized tests stemming from
sciences like nutrigenomics make their
supplements different
the supplement industry in general has a
lot of skeptics
we don't use kind of new ingredients
with very little research behind them
trying to make claims or have specific
results based on specific interventions
is definitely difficult
but routine claims their personalized
tests see positive results
over 80 percent of our members see
improvement in at least one health
metric things like improvement in energy
levels lower stress
as well as that immune immune sleep
but even with the claims from routine as
well as dozens of other personalized
nutrition companies the science still
has a long way to go
the thing about longevity is that it
takes a long time to study that's why we
call it longevity
when it comes to nutrigenomics we are
learning every day when we started doing
nutrigenomics we had about seven genes
that we were going over with with
patients now we have about 70.
some people really believe that once we
can map the entirety of food nutrition
interactions and map them in a way
that's inclusive of different sexes
ethnicities lifestyles then we can
arrive to this personalized precise
nutrition but on the other hand this
question is so complicated
that it might take a very long time for
us to get the answer
ultimately nutrigenomics isn't going
anywhere and it may be the way forward
with how we think about the food we eat
people are no longer interested in diets
they're interested in dietary patterns
that speak more to who they are and
embrace who they are personally and
genetically sociologically
it's hard to argue against our own
genetics in terms of determining what's
the best dietary approach for us
people are looking for what works they
want to live longer but people don't
want to just live longer anymore they
want to live better
[Music]
you